In this question, we're going to ask you to make
a persona. Now, doing this can be one of
the most difficult and intimidating thing that a designer
has to do, but it's really useful. So to try
and keep this very first persona as sort of
simple and straightforward as possible, we're going to ask that you
make it for yourself. And hopefully these two words
are throwing up a huge warning for you. Because it
almost, sounds like we're asking you to go down
the path of designing for yourself, but we're not. Normally,
you do not want to design yourself, and you won't
be doing that here. So why are we asking you
to do this? For one thing, we hope this
is an easy introduction to creating a persona, because it
really can be quite difficult. For another, what we want
to do is seed the discussion form, with a bunch
of authentic personas and use cases. In, in the next question you'll take the
personas and use cases created by classmates for themselves, and
build feature lists and flows for them. We've create a template in
Prezzy, and there's a link to it below that might help you out.